-Here's what people
are talking about.
You guys, today President Trump
gave a big speech
on national security.
He focused on the three biggest
threats to our country --
Russia, North Korea,
and Omarosa.
[ Laughter and applause ]
At one point he said,
"We will never
lose sight of our values
and their capacity
to inspire, uplift, and renew."
Then he realized someone left
an old Obama speech
in the teleprompter.
[ Laughter ]
"That doesn't sound like me
at all. What just happened?
Wall.
Come on, Donald, improvise."
[ Laughter ]
Covfefe.
Once again it seemed like
Trump's mouth
was getting a little dry.
You know he's been having
that problem.
Where he's like --
[ Laughs ]
You know -- United Shtates.
-Blesh United Shtates?
-Well, because his mouth
is getting dry.
-Reallish.
-Well anyways, take a look.
His mouth is getting a little...
-Where we are going
in the years ahead.
[ Lips smacking ]
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
-Well, I lost my appetite
forever. Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like a baby trying solids
for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
I wonder if he remembered
his water this time.
Did he have any water?
Calm down! Hey!
-Come on!
-I don't understand.
Who's talking to him?
Someone tell him he can't drink
water like that.
[ Laughter ]
That ought to really strike some
fear into our enemies.
"Don't you dare mess with us."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ah! Wa-Wa!
That's how a baby drinks
out of a sippy cup.
Ah, yummy.
[ Laughter ]
This is pretty crazy.
It was revealed
that the Pentagon
had a top secret program
to investigate UFOs and aliens.
Which is why
Trump announced plans
to build a dome over the Earth
and make E.T. pay for it.
[ Applause ]
"That seems like my speech."
[ Laughter ]
What's going on?
-Why would he do --
-I saw that yesterday --
No idea.
-Come on.
Even if he grabbed it, drank it,
and threw it away.
-I wouldn't care!
-That's so much tougher than...
-Just throw the water
in your face.
-...the double-handed baby sip.
-Better than that.
-Just pick it up, squirt it
like a Gatorade bottle.
Give him a sports bottle.
-Yeah.
-With the sports bottle,
you just go...
-Get like a boater bag.
Squeeze them in and out.
-Or like a camelback thing,
like a backpack with a tube
in his mouth.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Wouldn't care.
Silly straw.
-Did you guys see this?
There was
an 11-hour power outage
at the airport
in Atlanta yesterday.
And people were stranded on
the tarmac for six hours.
Don't worry, though.
Flight attendants
came through every hour
with a thimble-size cup of
room-temperature water.
That made them happy.
[ Applause ]
I'm sorry. Achoo!
Oh, I'm sorry.
Ooh, that spilled. Sorry.
-It's the perfect size.
-But this is nice.
[ Laughter ]
"They make glassware too large."
Hey, this is kind of funny.
I saw that Mark Hamill
and Ted Cruz
got into a Twitter fight over
net neutrality.
Got pretty heated at one point.
Hamill thought, "Oh, no.
Is this where I find out
Ted Cruz is my father?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Speaking of Ted, did you see --
hear about this?
Last night Donald Trump Jr.
posted a photo of
himself and Ted Cruz on
Instagram with the caption,
"Some good friends decided
they would get me
an early 40th birthday cake.
And what birthday is complete
without an Obama cake?"
Well, if you look closely
you can actually tell
what everyone in that photo
is thinking.
For example,
Don Jr. is thinking,
"I'm nailing this smile.
This is totally what a normal
person's smile looks like."
[ Applause ]
Next up, Ted Cruz is thinking,
"This is the first picture
in my life
where I've had
the best-looking face."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Obama is thinking,
"How did this dude get to be
40 years old
without learning the difference
between a cake and a cookie?"
[ Applause ]
Hey, you guys,
Christmas is just a week away,
and a lot of people are just
getting around
to doing
their Christmas shopping.
It can be a little stressful.
So here to help with some
last-minute Christmas gift ideas
please welcome
our holiday correspondent,
Julio Torres, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi. Hello.
-So great to see you.
Thank you.
Julio Torres, everybody. Hey.
-Hello, Jimmy, and ho, ho, ho.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, Julio,
last time you were here,
you had some
Halloween costume ideas
that were very conceptual
and almost impossible to get,
I would say.
-Yes. Yes, Jimmy.
I heard the feedback.
So none of that this time.
Just very, very easy ideas
anyone can get.
-Okay. Okay, great. Go ahead.
-Okay, first gift idea.
You've heard of tree skirts,
right?
-Mm-hmm.
-Well, how about tree pants?
Because even though
all Christmas trees are ladies,
some of them like to wear pants.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Here's another idea.
A miniature bridge that connects
your ear with your lover's ear
so that your hopes and dreams
can enter his head at night.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Julio, these seem to be
kind of hard to find.
-Okay. Well, how about
something easier,
like chandelier earrings
with little open flames?
Because no one ever said
beauty was easy.
[ Laughter ]
Or how about a golden hand
mirror that shows you
the reflection of your rival
when you say,
"Show me the girl"?
[ Laughter ]
-Julio, how about something
that people can order online?
-Yeah, sure. Like a platypus
that's like, "Guess what.
Bisexuality is real,
and so am I."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Or a locket with an old picture
of a soldier
who you've never met and yet
seems familiar but how?
[ Laughter ]
-What about, like, something
like socks or something?
-Why would anyone need socks,
Jimmy? No, no, no.
How about instead a music box
that can only be locked
from the inside
by the ballerina?
[ Laughter ]
Or an autographed picture of me
in a little bullfighter outfit.
Don't pretend you're not dying
to see that.
-I know a few people who would
love that, yeah.
-Or a big, gorgeous hat
you can wear
and slowly tilt up
to reveal your face
like Kate Winslet in "Titanic."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Or -- okay, how about a coffee
table book of your niece
posing for Christmas tree
pictures like this?
[ Laughter ]
And of course -- okay, this one
might be a little obvious,
but a locked little door that
comes with a small mail slot
through which tiny letters
appear every now and then,
but you can't open them
because they're addressed to
Umberto and that's not you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
What about just, like,
a nice candle?
-Jimmy, no. People are going to
think you're weird.
-Give it up for "Tonight Show"
holiday correspondent
Julio Torres.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Your hands --
They're a little wet.
-A little clammy.
-A little clammy,
not that clammy.
-Julio Torres right there.
Thank you, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, you guys, I read that
marijuana-infused wines
are coming to states
with legal weed.
Yep, something that makes you
drunk and high at the same time.
Then Nyquil said, "Uh, hello!"
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!